Here's how much it cost me to be a content creator last month.
First I had my chat bot software I use
and then what I use for my link in bio which is Stan Store.
I then paid for some supplies for an upcoming project from Joann
and then my phone payment,
my photo editing software,
and my email newsletter platform.
I then paid for my video editing app,
Instagram Meta verified, and then some Google storage.
I also ran a bunch of coffee giveaways this month as well.
That brings the total I spent this month at
three hundred and thirty dollars
and forty seven cents.
And I also had to buy a new phone which I didn't include in the total.